More than 450 Sudanese evacuate Yemen and arrive in Khartoum...
...after the Saudi-led military intervention escalated the fighting in Yemen.
In Nigeria, young women and girls march in one of many ceremonies...
...marking one year since more than 200 schoolgirls were kidnapped...
...by Islamic militants.
Security in the German city of Lubeck is high...
...ahead of the arrival of the G7 foreign ministers...
...for a two-day meeting expected to focus on Russia and Ukraine.
In China, five women's rights activists were unexpectedly released on bail...
...after a public outcry from the international community.
And finally from Indonesia, two Islamic parties seek legislation...
...that would ban all consumption of alcoholic drinks...
...and give jail terms of up to two years for offenders.